so very recently we have received new
concept art photos for Avengers infinity
war the photos are really cool they show
a lot of different scenes like Neda
Blair where Thor rocket and Groot go to
make Stormbreaker they show us parts
where Thanos is talking to the collector
they show us scenes where Thanos and the
black order arrives to Thor's s
guardianship and starts to you know
destroy everything there's a really cool
picture of nowhere that is just the
celestial head that is floating in space
there's a really cool photo of fan oohs
in his throne room with all of his black
order surrounding him there's a lot of
pictures of nowhere outside of nowhere
inside of nowhere the guardians of the
galaxy the Milano which is their ship
there's a couple of pics of the Battle
of Wakanda and there's a picture of
Captain America in the shadows that
shows him right before he catches
Proxima midnight spear there's a ton of
great pictures that we'll put in this
video but one picture in particular may
confirm an Avengers for theory and that
is the picture of Thanos farm at the end
of Avengers infinity war we saw vanos
finally getting to rest at his farm
after what he calls balancing the
universe mass genocide balancing the
universe same thing a lot of people
think that this is probably earth but
there has been a major Avengers 4 theory
that states that Thanos is actually on
Titan now a lot of people probably think
well Titan was destroyed and it's
uninhabitable and it's all red there's
no grass on it well you'd be right if we
were talking about the present time the
theory states that Thanos uses the time
stone to go back in time and live on a
Titan that is inhabitable so Thanos is
actually in the past and that is why the
Avengers have to travel to the past now
when this theory came out it was
dismissed by a lot of people some saying
that well he can't go back in time
because the Infinity Gauntlet is
destroyed which is true but he could
still use the time stone he could use
the time stone itself to go back in time
or he could use the time stone to fix T
Infinity Gauntlet and there are some
people saying that no this is just earth
but artists Pete Thompson did
favor when he posted this to his website
the title was Titan Thanos farm now some
people are saying that this could just
be a different part of Titan that hasn't
been destroyed but keep in mind
Santos through a moon at Titan it's
probably not okay and you can see pretty
far into the distance in this photo and
it's all green and not destroyed so it's
confirmed this is Titan and this is
where Thanos went at the end of infinity
warp to rest and watch the Sun rise and
it seems to be in a very beautiful state
so that leaves a question did danos use
the time stone to go back in time and is
this the reason why the Avengers have to
go back in time as well let me know what
you all think and let me know if you
have any theories of your own do you
think Fanus went back in time do you
think that he just found a part of Titan
that wasn't really destroyed or do you
think maybe he used the time stone just
on Titan and didn't go back in time
himself let me know how you feel in the
comments below if you enjoyed the video
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to my channel so you could stay up to
date on Avengers for everything Marvel
DC and superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you